and it's time for another 13 o'clock
movie retrospective another in our HP
lovecraft series yes is called beyond
reanimate err our accidental
Lovecraftian serious they should say I
think we've mentioned this before but
these just kind of all we watched all
these movies like within a you know
short time yeah within each other so you
know we kind of ended up doing a bunch
of them but this one is actually on to
be also right is how we ended up saying
it you can watch it for free at least it
was last time we we checked it's priced
ill there the thing about beyond
reanimate err it's like look everyone
that's into horror it's particularly
horror comedy has seen the original
re-animator from the 80s and you know
it's it's a cult classic bride of
re-animator which came out in 1990 that
one has like a little bit more of a
mixed reviews some people really loved
it some people really hated it so it's
kind of I don't remember it I haven't
seen it since we're probably 1991 or 92
so I'm not going to comment too much on
that we'll revisit it and we'll tell you
what we yeah so yeah because I haven't
seen it but actually I didn't know until
very recently that there is a third
movie in the series and that is beyond
reanimate er yeah I had seen this one I
like to even when I saw it what I saw
them I came out yeah I liked it yeah
this actually didn't come out until 2003
yeah and it's in the timeline so it does
actually occur thirteen years after the
events of brighter pre animator and this
was actually done by Brian Desna or use
now or however you pronounce his last
name I can't remember this is his
fantastic factory production company
based in Spain same people that did
Dagon so and the originals the earlier
yeah and he's the same guy that directed
bride of re-animator and he also
produced the original re animator which
of course was directed by Stuart Gordon
yeah now reanimate er is not really a
Lovecraft
tale it was inspired by a Lovecraft tale
yeah it's loosely based a very loosely
bit some like real hardcore Lovecraft
fans might say you know reanimate er is
not a Lovecraft movie reanimate ER and
the reanimate or series is like more
like a Jeffrey Combs movie
yeah and I would say yes it is there
Jeffrey Combs movies but there is enough
HP Lovecraft style influence in them to
where they are part of the genre if you
ask me yeah it's in the Lovecraft job
yeah it's kind of like well it's
Lovecraft akin to like a horror comedy
it's it's Lovecraft filtered through
Evil Dead yes I was just like you know
splat stick as they call it like you
know just really really gory
over-the-top kind of thing and it's
funny because I was watching some some
making-of features about this and Bryan
esna was saying that even from the
moment that Jeffrey Combs walked in to
audition for dr. Herbert West for the
first free animator they're like both
him and Stuart Gordon were like that's
him yeah we jittery a little sucker you
know I mean I knew he was me and now
that I think about it it's like can you
imagine anyone else playing that role
you can right I mean he's just the
embodiment of that character yeah I wish
she was in dagon it would have been
really that way and that would actually
would have been really good I mean as
much as I like Dagon that would have I
mean Jeffrey Combs his presence just
elevates anything I don't care what it
is you can put him in any movie you know
a minion backs it out it calms knocked
it out of the park with the frighteners
- I really like like so creepy
nobody plays creepy and weird like
Jericho yeah and he was good on the Star
Trek and DISA is
Deep Space Nine and star trek and I yeah
yeah yeah he needs to be in more movies
I mean he's been in a lot and the thing
that's cool about Jeffrey Combs is that
he doesn't seem light and I don't know I
don't know him personally but he doesn't
seem he seems to take the horror genre
very seriously
cuz you know that some actors
particularly ones that were in sort of
iconic horror movies in the 70s and 80s
you know later on were like well they
wanted to go on to more serious
quote-unquote movie roles and they you
know cuz I think horror still had kind
of a you know it was sort of a
ghettoized sort of thing where it wasn't
as good and that was just like a
stepping stone so I always admire horror
actors that are willing to be in horror
movies and really like the genre and
don't see it as just like oh well this
is I couldn't get in real movies
quote-unquote so I'll just be in these
horror movies
seeing the work that Combs did on Star
Trek Enterprise he played Shran
commander Shran who was like an Andorian
military officer forgotten and man he
was spot-on as an ex-military guy he was
spot-on for a hardcore military officer
he was kind of like an alien version of
Patton yeah yeah he was weldin I loved
his work as Randy yeah
all right so beyond reanimate err and
here's the thing and here's one thing
that I saw some little horror nerds were
getting all upset about they said well
there shouldn't have been a third one
because Herbert West supposedly died at
the end of bride of re-animator I was
like yeah well he supposedly died at the
beginning of the first one do and yet
they made breath afraid a minute guys
weren't bitching about that so you know
I'm not gonna get to in this show it's a
horror comedy genre you can do whatever
you want pretty much you can especially
a franchise that is so invested in this
sort of over the top like comedic it's
not you know it's not supposed to be
realistic or anything like that so you
can I'm not gonna get to we saw this
free on to be yeah but there's a bunch
of different special editions of this
and I actually want to get this on
blu-ray actually there's a really nice
and I just saw it I was looking somebody
was reviewing the whole box set there's
a whole fantastic factory box set you
know from from Brian yeses production
company that has this movie and it has a
bunch of other ones that he made into
like a rack knit and some other does it
have Dagon in it it mmm does it it might
cuz I got to get that on blu-ray but um
there's good I really like like the
artwork for it was really good like all
the cover art was really nice and
there's like it looked like there was a
really lot of extras because there's a
special release Dagon blu-ray what nuts
coming at the end of this month in it I
think it's right and it's just I think
it's a steelbook edition I gotta get you
really yeah really do you need to get
that so that's good maybe now this one
beyond reanimate er like I said I kind
of went back and forth and I was looking
at other people's reviews because I was
kind of curious this one seems to fall
mostly mixed reviews there were a lot of
really positive ones a few like kind of
negative ones some people liked it
better than bride of re-animator some
people thought it was worse than
bride of re-animator I mean you have to
go into it it's like obviously it's
never going to live up to the original I
mean because that's a classic yeah but
on the other hand I liked this one like
I said I haven't seen bride of
re-animator in a long time I remember
liking this one more now this one to me
seemed more like a black comedy yeah it
didn't have a lot of serious stuff in it
and all of them were kind of like that
and right but I felt like this one was
more in that direction I like the
setting is happening in prison yeah it's
a phrase that was pretty cool
lots of practical effects yeah so it
kind of has an old-school feeling in the
execution but the quality is higher yeah
then the first reanimate er I thought in
terms of special effects well they
obviously spent a lot more money on it I
think all all three of the movies like I
said I haven't seen the second one oh
yeah I think I have seen it but I
haven't seen it recently right I've seen
it it was probably like 20 years it to
that I can remember the first one in
this one I put them you know in the same
playing field yeah I like them both yeah
they're there each one of them is their
own movie they're definitely part of
that same genre yeah I mean I can tell
that I can tell if this is the same team
working on it in my in my mind if you
like the first one you'd like this one
too yeah
probably fans are really hard to please
yeah actually hardcore fans they start
nerding out and geeking out like crazy
and they're constantly gonna say hey it
doesn't live up to the original and
that's just with all movies 2001 is like
that yeah you're always gonna get that
it's hard to live up to terminator 1
even though that was a cheap low-budget
flick but there was just something about
the you know the magic of when you're
seeing it you know there I think there's
also nostalgia you're young when you see
it it's new it makes them yeah it's hard
to kind of separate that you have a high
expectation right next one comes and it
doesn't quite meet up with your
unrealistically high expectations I
always like to let these movies age and
go back and look at them sometimes when
you see them much later on yeah I better
appreciate the pressures off you know
right
like for instance I like some swartz
nega movies I don't like em all but I
like about half a sixth day which came
out in was 2003 universally panned I
went back
recently man I loved it I really loved
it and then I'm reading other reviews
and people said the same thing I saw
this when it came out hated it but
looking at it now man this is a great
movie
yeah and it's because the pressure is
off yeah what something's new you're
scrutinizing it that's why it's good to
like revisit things I think a long time
even if you didn't like it at the time
yeah if it was something you felt like
you should have liked right give it ten
years and then Wow but the thing about
beyond REE animators I like it's it's
actually some people are calling it it's
almost kind of like a remake of the
first one the structure of the story is
very similar though the setting is
different so dr. Herbert West apparently
in 1990 which is there's like a little
cold open at the beginning where he gets
arrested because of this whole thing
where one of his zombies escapes and it
kills this girl and this little boy like
sees the hole that the girl's little
brother sees it happen and sees dr. West
getting taken away and find some of the
reagent so then you cut ahead to 2003
and dr. West is in prison and has been
there for 13 years and he's still
working on his experiments but obviously
he's in prison so he can't get a lot of
stuff he's working in the prison
hospital yeah and the infirmary of Emory
right so he's kind of just experimenting
on rats and stuff like that but one
thing that's cool about this because
what you know what they did in the
original reanimate er you know obviously
he figures out to brain how to bring
people back from the dead and it's you
know reagent the reagent but it went in
the back they're not quite right now in
the second one bride of re-animator he
figures out how to do like just body
parts and then he's gonna put together a
body like dr. Frankenstein or whatever
now in this one I liked that they they
took it another step further because dr.
West has discovered this little thing
essentially it's a soul but it's like a
scientific electrical kind called nano
plasmic energy yeah it's like
bioelectricity right spirit and you can
take it from a person and then you know
if you put it back in them after they
die
yeah or you or you can translate it from
one to another then they'll come back as
a zombie but they'll be normal run
theory yeah must be kind of like soul
energy that's great looking so
like that they kind of upped the stakes
so it's like now they're not just
bringing people back in their crazy
zombies our drivers like I said in
theory they're trying to restore people
to the way they were before they died
like by implanting this quote-unquote
soul so he's discovered that in the
interim now then you get this new little
you know kind of wide-eyed prison doctor
that shows up and you know knows who he
is
who knows who he is now the prison is
supposed to be in Massachusetts yeah but
obviously this was filmed in Spain
almost all the actors are Spanish so
most of them have been dubbed I'm not
sure cuz I even noticed that this is I
know some people don't like that and
that was something that some of the
reviews pointed out they said oh the
dubbings bad or I didn't even notice
that it was I did but it didn't it
wasn't distracting with you because I
did know that it was shot in Spain so I
knew that most of the actors had thick
Spanish accent so they did dub everyone
whenever I'm seeing a movie like this I
just roll with it I'm not ready to I'm
not scrutinizing I don't mean do you do
you really scrutinize now like local
dead I don't scrutinize even well like I
said I'm kind of like unless a movie is
really boring or if it's like
aggressively stupid or insulting or
something like that quality is just bad
or the quality is bad I'm very willing
to sit there and go okay take me
somewhere right and if like even if I
don't like it at the end I'd be like
okay well I can respect what they're
trying to do I'm not you know I'm not
one of those people just thinks every
movie is good obviously there are a lot
of shitty movies out there but I'm
willing to sit back and kind of put my
expectations on hold to see what this
person wants to show me the movie makers
I thought the quality of the movie was
really good I mean it had a lot of
old-school effects yeah right the
writing was good editing and the pacing
was awesome execution I thought was
really good and I was just having fun I
was rolling with it I wasn't you know
scrutinizing it like that yeah I wasn't
might even know it doesn't even notice
that it was dubbed like I said I did
notice it but it wasn't something that
was like super distracting because like
I said I mean coming from someone who
I'm a big fan of Italian movies
particularly jell-o movies and pretty
much all of those are dubbed so it's
kind of you know they've dubbed everyone
into English because everyone spoke
different languages so it's not
something that is you know that's really
noticeable for me because I've seen so
movies that were like that yeah for me
the energy of the movie was good so I
was just rolling so this was actually it
was filmed in a I think I guess well at
least the exteriors were filmed in a
real prison in Valencia Spain and like I
said all the actors are our Spanish but
except for you know a few but so you
know this little doctor comes and he
turns out he's the grown-up brother of
this sister you know that got killed by
one of West Somme bees back in 1990 and
he has become so fascinated by West's
work that he's like I specifically
requested to come to this prison so I
could work with you and now they're like
trying to do you know they're trying to
put together so so he has like a guy on
the outside who can bring him supplies
and stuff like that so he can continue
his work inside the prison now the best
I really the best part about this I mean
there's like all the characters are kind
of over the top a little bit like
especially the warden who's like this
fascist you know he's like who gets off
on like electrocuting prisoners and all
this other kind of stuff and you know
kind of wants to be able to sustain
their torture like after they die and
show like that so he's kind of like one
of the main vaccinations they're really
sadistic yeah yeah so and then there's
like you know there's kind of a lot of
characters like among the other
prisoners and stuff like that but the
best thing about this movie is like the
last third like after the whole prison
riot takes place and everything like
that I mean if you if you like the
reanimate or series you know that one of
the hallmarks of it is just this crazy
like over-the-top
run gore and like all these two like
crazy set pieces and stuff like that and
this really does not disappoint in that
department
I delivered I really really was very
wildly entertained yeah a lot of if
you've never seen a reanimate or movies
and I would probably like to say that
it's very similar to a Evil Dead movie
yeah it's yeah it's creepy creepy stuff
happens that maybe they'd be scary if
you're a kid but for the most part
they're just kind of entertaining it's a
lot of cartoon gore do you not really
taking it too seriously you're just
having fun with it and you and you're
waiting to see which direction they're
gonna go yeah in some kind of crazy
story that's what I mean it's like cool
and
really does have a lot of really I mean
used from that the opening shots of that
zombie coming in a drink in the milk
with no jaw like the yet he kind of
looked like the zombie from Dawn of the
Dead or day yeah you know there one word
one prisoner he's like just a torso with
hands and he's like running around the
prison and yeah and then another thing
that's weird you know we're talking
about this bioplasmic soul energy that
they have I mean there's a lot of
mix-ups that happen with this like the
bioenergy of a rat accidentally gets
injected into a human
well not accidentally it was kind of dr.
Weston yeah it was it was on purpose but
and then what happens to a human when
they have the soul of a rat you know
that's because what are the coolest
things and like I said I think this is
why Jeffrey Combs just makes this whole
series yeah is because you know you can
argue a via Slee he's a mad scientist
obviously he's crazy but the way that I
mean he just keeps his cool pretty much
and he's very detached which i think is
what makes all of the over-the-top gore
and stuff like that that's what works
like that juxtaposition so his whole
theory is that yeah I got this little
soul and you keep it in this little
light bulb or whatever it's like a
little electrical spark and he's like oh
well it doesn't matter like you can
transfer transfer it from a rat to a
human you can transfer it from a human
to a human it's like you know it's a
neutral energy so it shouldn't matter in
theory
obviously right since this is a
reanimated movie you know that that's
it's not going to go the way he says
it's going to go but I like the way he's
very detached he's like oh well it
shouldn't matter I can put a rat thing
in a person and it won't make any
difference because the life spark is a
life spark but like I said that's not
how it works out and there's also like I
said just the gore and this is so funny
like the gags are so funny you get to
see what happens when a living person
injects the reagent people explode
people's faces get killed off a
reanimated rat fights of reanimated
particular body part yeah I don't know I
don't know if our friend Shona has seen
this but she would love this movie yeah
yeah this is definitely want to see it
super super fun it's just like one of
those crazy gory popcorn type of movies
yeah and here's the interesting thing
now ever since back in I guess 2006 or
something like that because I'm gonna
say the end of this movie kinda seems
like it could be setting up a sequel
right yeah you know well evidently ever
since 2006 they've been thrown around
the idea of doing a fourth movie in the
series that's right because called house
of reanimate er is usually what it's
called because spoiler alert now that I
remember it Herbert West escaped prison
he escapes at the end yeah yeah that's
what I mean he gets out like during the
riot and all the crazy [ __ ] that happens
I'd be awesome yeah I guess so it really
did seem like they were setting it up
for another movie right but I don't know
if it's ever gonna get made now I've
heard that Stuart Gordon wanted to come
back and do it um you know that Jeffrey
Combs wanted to do it things have
changed so much right you know you they
could raise the money so easily for this
well that's a nice yeah that's what I'm
saying and actually one of the other
reviews that I read like said that it's
like why don't they start a Kickstarter
every animator has so many fans look
what happened with MST right like 7
million dollars or something like that
like to bring the show back right and I
kind of feel like they could probably do
that it was a good company and they and
Kickstarter could probably really help
them out I mean I'm sure they I know
they have enough fan base to get
together special release blu-rays yeah
you would think which is with proper
marketing they could really unify their
product repackage it yeah it's some
Kickstarter support start pumping out
movies because I like the movies I would
definitely see another one especially if
Stuart Gordon got back in bed I spent
and obviously Jeffrey Combs has to be
involved otherwise it's by every blu-ray
they'd made from that company yeah I've
been happy with everything that they
those guys have made yeah and you know
so hopefully like I said but it's it's
been more than ten years since they
first started kicking that idea around
and they haven't done it so far there
was actually from what I heard the
fourth one that was actually gonna be
the start of like another trilogy yeah
you know what I mean so but the first
one is really the only one I've ever
seen I saw like kind of a random plot
synopsis
it and it sounded kind of cool it
sounded like a good idea so I don't know
I don't know if that will ever get made
and all of us he comes back I like I
said I'd like him in anything he's just
he's just like the best any time you
need like a weird twitchy yeah creepy
little sucker and the thing is and if
any of you have met him in real life I'd
really like to know because he seems
like he'd be really nice dude I bet he's
not even like weird at all
like if you mean I don't know though
I've seen the little clips of him just
talking and responded to questions he
just seems like a normal guy that's what
I got him funny yeah like I've seen like
interviews when I was watching like the
making of the various films and there's
interviews with him and he does seem
variable just kind of like a funny funny
guy kind of dude
but yes you know this there's another
company that we're gonna introduce
people to also remember there's a little
company making like vintage authentic
Lovecraftian story yeah yeah we have to
we have to get their blu-rays the HP
Lovecraft Historical Society yeah and
they're done in the context of the time
of HP Lovecraft yeah so one of them is a
silent move and the other one is a
talkie and they they look very vintage
their little fan films and they're from
the one that we saw very high-quality
yeah we saw which was the silent films
size and they did it just like an
old-school silent film as if it was made
at the time and it nipped fantastic it
looks like the original King Kong with
the claim emotions yeah yeah it's quite
so they made another one they made
whisper in the dark and we have we have
to see that we're gonna what we're gonna
do is gonna order both of those blu-rays
and then we'll probably just do both of
those movies like on one episode right
that's gonna be a while though but yeah
yeah plug them because for the product
that I saw it looks pretty cool but
they're there they say they want premium
prices well like I said it's a small
company and you know an off type stuff
the cool clothes they had some posters
and like yeah sure yeah they had
searched yes it's some other really cool
merch and they're kind of and I think
they kind of promote other other Studios
work too like they kind of sell that
through their website so yeah that's um
that's definitely something we're gonna
be doing way down the line I remember
like I said we saw Call of Cthulhu I
think we just we paid to see that on
YouTube yeah and then but it's not there
anymore no it's not and I
actually really like to own it and then
you got to get whisper in the dark too
because that looks really cool I saw the
trailers yeah so yeah we're definitely
so we'll definitely be doing more
Lovecraft in the future although after
this we'll probably be go off and do
like a few other type of movies before
we get back to the Lovecraft stuff but
we hope you guys have enjoyed this
review of beyond reanimate err like I
said it's up there on to be good it's up
there on to be if you like the original
reanimate err you'll probably like this
one too it's a you know in the same
spirit you know even though it's got
mixed reviews all over the place but
most people don't listen to those things
well most people gave it a pretty
positive video so you know if you're
into horror comedies or into the
reanimate or series I don't see any
reason why you wouldn't like it and it's
free to watch on to be so go and check
it out and tell us what you thought down
in the comments and remember if you
liked our show to like share subscribe
and tell all your friends about us and
be sure to tune in to our regular
episodes which come out every Tuesday
and our movie reviews which come out
every Friday if you'd like to
financially support the show we have a
patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast and also a blog at 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation so until next time we
will see you then bye